greetings to my 3abn family and welcome
to another 3abn today Bible q a my name
is Ricky Carter and I'm going to be your
host today today we've got another hour
pact of your Bible questions and we've
got the answers from the word of God
Amen and I've got my illustrious panel
here who's going to be sharing with you
those answers let me introduce you to
them
to my right I have sister Shelly Quinn
welcome sister Shelley it's always a
blessing to be on this program it's we
want to thank you for your questions
it's always fun to get the answers for
you straight from the word amen amen and
to her a right to have brother denzy
brother John Dinsey welcome brother
Dinsey it's a pleasure to be here and
it's always a delight to read God's word
because God has infinite Treasures of
knowledge amen praise the Lord
and next to him I have Pastor John
lomachane welcome Pastor John always
good to be here I'm continually learning
thank you for your challenging questions
it's a blessing to be on this program
amen amen amen
well before we get into our program we
always want to start off by having a
word of prayer asking God to give us
wisdom to understand his word
brother denzy can you share some of
God's precious word with us or I should
say pray for us sure let's go to the
Lord in prayer
our loving and wonderful Heavenly Father
we thank you so much because you love us
so much thank you for your mercy that is
beyond our understanding We Praise You
Lord because you have invited us to
learn from you
we pray that in this program we will
also learn from you again if we pray for
your Holy Spirit to be upon us that we
may speak those words that are answers
to the questions your children have
asked and we pray for your blessing upon
all that stop to listen to this program
we pray that this program will awaken
them and awaken in them a desire to
study the holy scriptures to ask you in
the holy and blessed name of Jesus
amen amen
well before we get into our first
question I want to invite our viewers at
home let them know how they can
participate amen so you can participate
by texting your questions to
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 or for those of you who
want to email you can email us at
bibleqa at
3abn.tv that's bibleqa at 3abn.tv and
then for those of you who are on
Instagram you can send your questions
that way at 3abn underscore official
that's 3abn underscore official all
right well let's get started
Pastor John I want to give you the first
question okay
question number one before we were
conceived what kind of beings were we
and how long were we in that form that's
from Darlene in North Dakota and she
texted that to us okay well thank you
darling for the question I know you're
answering asking and sincerity but let
me inform you we humans don't have a
pre-existence in some faiths or some
religions they teach like incarnation
uh and some other religions use a
different terminology uh simply
summarizing the cycles of life but the
Bible doesn't teach that we had a
pre-existence and then some people
allude to that when a loved one dies and
the Bible says the Lord told Adam in
Genesis he says from dust you are unto
dust you shall return you'll till the
ground until you return from which you
came from Dash you are to dust you shall
return
so the Lord made it clear any prior form
we would dust and that dust Genesis 2 7
the bible says in the Lord God formed
man of the Dust of the ground and
breathed into his Naturals a breath of
life a Man became a living being or a
living Soul so there was no existence
outside of that like living in heaven or
having a former life this is pretty
direct question but
how long did the Lord know us is another
question and Jeremiah talks about the
formation of the person in Jeremiah 1 5.
the Lord looks at us in the context of
I've got plans for that little boy when
he's born so when my mom conceived me I
talked about this and I was this little
packet she thought she was uh had a
stomachache or something and back then
there was no ultrasounds and so she went
to get exploratory surgery
found out that I was neatly tucked on
there and closed her up and I was a
result many months later
and the Lord says in Jeremiah 1 5 before
I formed you in the womb I knew you so
we are being formed in the womb amen he
said before you were Sanctified I
ordained you a prophet to the Nations
and I'd like to think that the Lord had
plans for my life before I was born
because look at me today
um Mom and Dad were not married I was
born out of wedlock and the Lord took my
life in a completely different direction
so I would say my pre-existence was in
the heart and mind of the Lord I wasn't
there physically but God has plans for
everyone's alive amen there's not a
person that's born on the planet that
has an advantage over the other but when
you commit your way to the Lord trust
also in him and he'll bring it to pass
if you give the Lord if you commit your
way to the Lord he'll give you the
desires of your heart as long as they
are in harmony with his will and Isaiah
44 verse 2 we read thus says the Lord
who made you informed you from the womb
that's where it starts the form Nation
no prior existence than that who will
help you fear not oh Jacob my servant
and you justuron whom I have chosen so
he forms Us in the womb but there is no
prior formation to that
amen amen thank you sir
all right sister Shelley yes sir I have
your first question you ready I'm ready
right
what is meant by the seven spirits of
god mentioned in Revelation chapter 1
verse 4 Before the Throne
chapter 4 verse 7 7 lamps and Chapter 5
Verse 6 seven horns and eyes and that
was a emailed question okay and it's a
great question let's look to the word
when you're looking at Revelation this
is a book of signs and symbols and the
secret to understanding Revelation is to
find its first use in the Bible now
let's look at this Revelation 1 4 and 5
because we find the answers to
Revelation in the Old Testament
Revelation 1 4 and 5 John's writes to
the seven churches grace to you and
peace and he's going to say peace from
three sources from him who is and who
was and who is to come and from the
seven spirits who are before his throne
and from Jesus Christ the faithful
witness so Grace peace from three
co-equal persons of the godhead and he
goes on and when he says
to him who loved us and washed us from
his sins and his own blood now
the number seven
symbolically in the Bible is the number
of perfection it is the number of
completion the seven spirits that is
talking about here this is the
Perfection of the Holy Spirit and the
Holy Spirit is spoken of or referred to
as a seven-fold spirit in Isaiah 11 2.
let's look at that because in these
Isaiah 11 2 it says the Spirit of the
Lord so there he is the spirit of
holiness
the
shall rest upon him the spirit of wisdom
that's his second fold the spirit of
understanding the spirit of counsel and
might the spirit of knowledge and of the
fear of the Lord so the sevenfold Holy
Spirit is pictured in Revelation 1 as
standing Before the Throne ready for
service now let's look at Revelation 4
and verse 5. from this Throne preceded
lightning thunderings and voices seven
lamps of fire were burning Before the
Throne which are the seven spirits of
God remember this is the number of
perfection if we look to Zechariah 4 2
we see a vision of the Holy Spirit
and Zechariah sees a golden lamp stand
with the bowl and seven lamps and he
asks oh Lord what is it and the Lord
answered verse 6 Zechariah 4 6 he
answered and said to me not by might nor
by power but by my spirit so these seven
lamps oh we see in Zechariah now we see
here at the throne Revelation 5 6 says I
looked and behold in the midst of the
Throne of four living creatures in the
midst of the elders stood a lamb as
though it had been slain having seven
horns that's the lamb that refers to the
Lamb's perfect strength and seven eyes
which are the seven spirits of God sent
out into all the Earth those seven eyes
are the perfect omniscience of the
spirit Psalm 139 verse 7. David says
where can I go from your spirit where
can I flee from your presence amen thank
you for that answer sister
all right brother Dinsey I have your
first question you ready yes here we go
can you explain Luke chapter 16 verse 9
and that's from Helena and she sent it
in Via Instagram
very good uh well Elena uh I can begin
to give you an answer and but we need to
give you a little context about Luke 16
9 Luke 69 is a continuation of something
Jesus was describing before about an
unjust Steward so this begins really in
Luke chapter 16 verse 1.
uh it says here he also said to his
disciples there was a certain rich man
who had a steward and an accusation was
brought to him that this man was wasting
his Goods so he called unto him and said
what is this that I hear about you give
an account of your stewardship so for
you can no longer be a steward
then the steward said within himself
what shall I do for my Master's taking
the stewardship away from me I cannot
dig I'm ashamed to beg I have resolved
what to do that when I am put out of the
stewardship they may receive me into
their houses so he called one of his
master's debtors to him and said first
how much do you owe my my master and he
said 100 measures oil so he said to him
take your bill quickly and write down
50. so he did this with all of the
people that owed so when he was put out
of the stewardship
they he already had friends because he
did them some favor but actually they
participated in some of the evil work
that he was doing
so Jesus says and I say to you make
friends for yourself by unrighteous
Mammon that when you fail they may
receive you into an everlasting home
well what is unrighteous Mammon
unrighteous Mammon in this context is
the riches of the world
so Jesus is saying to them take the
riches of the world that is the money
and use that to benefit others that's
what Jesus is is presenting here and so
he's talking to scribes and Pharisees
notice I'm going to give you now Matthew
Luke chapter 16 verses 9 through 13. and
I say to you make friends for yourselves
by your unrighteous Mammon that when you
fail they may receive you into
Everlasting home he who is faithful and
that which is least is faithful also and
much and he who is unjust in what is
least is unjust also in much therefore
if you have not been faithful in
unrighteous Mammon if you have been
faith if you have been unfaithful that
is and if you have have not been
faithful in the use of money who will
commit to you the true riches and if you
have not been faithful to what is
another man's who will give you what is
your own no man no servant can serve two
masters for either he will hate the one
and love the other or else he will be
loyal to the one and despise the other
you cannot serve God and Mammon so Jesus
is talking about uh if you have riches
if you have Goods do use this to benefit
others so that if something happens to
you you fail you already have made
friends with people that they will have
pity on you you were kind to them you
were nice to them they will be nice to
you when you have your difficult time so
this is really uh some of the context
you see here by make use uh wisely of
unrighteous Mammon that when you fail
you may be received into an everlasting
home amen thank you for that answer I
was wondering about that answer myself
so that gave me the answer all right
amen Pastor let me Kane I've got your
second question
Numbers chapter 22 verse 20 states that
God told Balaam to go
but verse 22 says God's anger was
kindled with him because he went
this is a bit confusing could you shed
some light on this puzzling text please
this is a classic case of I want to go
but mommy told me I can't and I start
with a kind of tongue-in-cheek
description that way because Balaam was
a person whose motives for serving God
was shifting
he was a man that God chose to be a
spokesperson
but the enemies as we read the story in
Numbers chapter 22
we could start around verse 10.
and um he was invited you see the
Israelites were growing in number large
in size and and uh the enemy was
concerned that they're going to
outnumber us and we might be in trouble
so they said to Balaam I know you work
for God but could you just maybe take a
vacation from God and come and curse
Israel for us
and so God steps in in verse
9 then God came to Balaam and said who
are these men with you so Balaam said to
God balach the son of the poor king of
Moab has sent to me
saying look a people has come out of
Egypt and they cover the face of the
Earth come now curse them for me perhaps
I shall be able to overpower them and
drive them out
right here is where the story should
have ended
verse 12 and God said to Balaam you
shall not go with them you shall not
curse the people for they are blessed
story should have ended right there
but the morning came and Baylor was kind
of Baylor Balaam said to you know God
told me not to go with you
that should have ended the story
so the king heard that Balaam wasn't
coming they sent more men more Honorable
Men that kind of sweetened the pot
and um
Balaam responded the very same way in
verse 18 though you were to give me a
house full of silver and gold I could
not go beyond the word of the Lord my
God to do less or more but here is the
problem verse 19. now therefore
please you also stay here tonight that I
may know what the Lord will say to me
I already told you God already told him
what not to do he already said God told
me even if you gave me as much money as
you wanted I'm not going but still the
night see what God might he might change
his mind and God saw balaam's divided
heart and say okay go with them when
they ask you to go to see if Balin would
disobey God's word who said don't go no
matter what the next morning he went
and God's anger was canceled against him
that's how you revealed a person's
motive God revealed the hidden motive of
balaam's heart
and Balaam was for purchase and when
they sweetened the pot Balaam said God
said don't go I don't care how much you
give me
but stay overnight and see if God will
change his mind and the next that during
that God said we'll just call it go with
them go with them
and he went and got us man I thought I
told you in the very beginning not to go
but that's what happens when like the
children of Israel who are not satisfied
with the man or they want to Quail God
said here's the quail it's another one
of those circumstances when you disobey
God God will use your own motives to
reveal your hidden secrets amen amen
thank you for that answer pastor
all right
sister Shelley yes I've got your second
question
is there a difference between sin
iniquity and transgression that's from
Ted who emailed that in
Ted what a great question everybody has
this question all three terms mean
unrighteousness it's a departure from
God's righteous standards so all sin is
evil in the eyes of a holy God it
offends him first John 5 17 says all
unrighteousness is sin so when we think
of God he is perfectly righteous moral
he cannot sin sin is moral worthlessness
it's it's an absence of God's morality
so let's look at Psalm 32 verse 5
because we're going to see all three
terms in this David writes in Psalm 32
verse 5. I acknowledged my sin to you
and my iniquity I have not hidden I said
I will confess my transgression to the
Lord and you forgave the iniquity of my
sin sin is to miss the holy standards of
God Romans 3 23 says all have sinned and
fallen short of the glory of God First
John 3 4 says that whoever commits sin
is committing lawlessness it's acting
like God has no boundaries on us no laws
to follow and it says sin is lawlessness
transgression is a little bit different
because it means to
disrespectfully
disobey God's Sovereign Authority it
means that you are presumptuously to
transgress is to cross over his
boundaries of love that he has put in
place for our well-being The Ten
Commandments are his Charter of Rights
for his government of Love
iniquity is lawlessness it's
premeditated wickedness and evil in we
see this with David and Bathsheba and
Uriah what he did job 4 8 says even as I
have seen those who plow iniquity those
who think about this and plan out this
evil they so
they so trouble they reap the same
Isaiah 53 5 says that Jesus was wounded
for a transgressions he was bruised for
our iniquities and the chastisement of
our peace and well-being was upon him
and by his stripes by his wounds we are
healed and made whole you know the
beauty of God's Everlasting Covenant the
goal of the Covenant is second
Corinthians 5 21 that God made him who
knew no sin to be sin for us that we
might become the righteousness of God in
Christ Jesus so when we sin count on
first John 1 9 if we confess our sins
he's faithful in just to forgive us our
sins and cleanse us of all
unrighteousness amen amen thank you
sister
okay brother Dinsey here's your second
question
if Satan knows the scriptures
why does he persist in his work knowing
his end that question was emailed to us
that's a good question
and you you wonder why you you already
know you're lost why you keep doing this
well the Bible does shed some light uh
it's he has become so
for so long has practice evil he refused
us to do right Revelation chapter 12
verse 10 to 12 says then I heard a loud
voice saying in heaven now salvation and
strength and the kingdom of our God and
the power of His Christ have come for
the accuser of our Brethren who accused
them before our Our God day and night
has been cast down they overcame him by
the blood of the lamb and by the word of
their testimony and they did not love
their lives to the death therefore
Rejoice all heavens and you who dwell on
them woe to the inhabitants of the earth
and the Sea for the devil has come down
to you having great wrath because he
knows he has a short time he has lost he
knows he has a short time he has given
himself totally to doing evil and to
bring down as many as he can with him
Jesus describes the condition of the
devil John 8 44 you are of your father
the devil he speaks to the scribes and
Pharisees and the desires of your father
he you want to do he was a murderer from
the beginning and does not stand in in
the truth because there is no truth in
him there's no truth there's no love in
him when he speaks a lot he speaks from
his own resources for he is a liar and
the father of it and this is his
condition uh John chapter 3 verse 24
everyone practicing evil hates the light
and does not want to come to the light
lest his deeds should be exposed he is
pure evil and uh in John 15 18
and 19 it speaks as if this is speaking
of the devil if the world hates you if
the devil hates you you know that he
hated me before he hated you if you were
of the world the world would the world
would love its own if you were of the
devil he would love you in some degree
but he even even those that identify
with him he does them harm
and yet because you are not of the world
but I chose you out of the world
wherefore the world hates you Satan
hates God's people because they want to
do God's will they identify with God so
he goes to do them harm this is what you
see in Revelation chapter 12
and I'm just going to read verse 17 at
this point and the dragon was enraged
with the woman and he went to make war
with the rest of her Offspring who keep
the Commandments of God and have the
testimony of Jesus Christ he just hates
God's people
uh unfortunately he's not going to
change and in Ezekiel chapter 28 verses
and through through 19 you will see that
the Bible does say that he will be
destroyed
amen it's in the scriptures uh let me
see if I can read some of it for you
because uh let me see because of the
multitude of the merchandise have filled
the midst of thee with violence and thou
has sin therefore I will cast thee out
of the profane
the Mountain of God and I will destroy
the covering chair from the midst of the
stones of fire and it continues to say
he will become ashes and be no more read
it in Ezekiel chapter 28 verses 16-19
amen amen thank you sir thank you
well Pastor John before I give you your
third question I want to remind the
viewers at home how they can participate
sure
so you can send in your questions by
email
to Bible QA
at 3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv or
for those of you who would like to text
us you can text us at
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 and then for those of you
who are Instagram you can send us your
questions at 3abn underscore official
that's a 3abn underscore official
all right Pastor John here's your third
question and this is an opportunity to
give a four-minute answer okay
after the devil and wicked are destroyed
in the Lake of Fire and God makes a new
Earth evil and sin will not rise up a
second time amen
will we be capable of sinning in the new
Earth and that was texted to us okay
thank you for the question the answer
the quick answer is no and let me tell
you the reason why let me go ahead and
justify it the whole issue that we are
living in right now is the controversy
between good and evil light and darkness
sin and righteousness and we are now
making a choice about how we want
eternity to be formed
eternity would be an awful existence if
the possibility of sin coming back
exactly would be one of the options on
the table Even in our human choices in
our human nature and I use the word
human nature intentionally because of
human nature were going into the kingdom
yes it would be it will be possible but
first John chapter 3 verse 2 says
beloved now we are children of God and
it has not yet been revealed what we
shall be but we know that when he is
revealed we shall be like him amen for
we shall see him as he is now if we are
like Jesus let me tell you what comes
with that
okay we are not like Jesus before his
resurrection will be like Jesus after
his resurrection what does that mean
when Jesus came forth from the grave
what he what did he do he conquered
death he conquered sin and he came forth
with all authority all power to be
perfectly
perfectly perfect from that point on in
human flesh but not in sinful flesh and
that nature would be transferred to us
in the resurrection now we have the
sanctifying process happening now that's
why it says it has not yet been revealed
what we shall be
but we know that when he is revealed we
will be like him what does that like him
mean
this corruptable
will put on incorruption meaning you
cannot be corrupted amen this Mortal
will put on immortality meaning you
can't die here's the reasons why you
can't die
Revelation 21 4 there shall be no more
death amen if there's no more death
there's no more sin so sin cannot if
death is not going to be there then sin
obviously won't be there because the
wages of sin is death The Last Enemy
that shall be destroyed is death
Revelation 20 14 death and Hades or Hell
will be cast into the Lake of Fire this
is the second death death is the end
result of sin if there's going to be no
more death there'll be no more sin then
and Nam 1 9 says Affliction will not
rise up a second time now here's the
thing somebody might say well are we
losing choices let me give you a classic
example if you came to my house you
wouldn't find alcohol you wouldn't find
prom you wouldn't find immorality you
wouldn't find drugs or you wouldn't find
paraphernalia for pipes and cigarettes
am I taking away your choice no
you're coming to a home where those
don't exist
when we go to heaven where are we going
when you read Revelation chapter 22 not
Bible says in revelation 22 nothing that
defiles will enter in it amen so if
nothing that defiles can enter into it
for outside our dogs and Sorcerers and
whoremongers but nothing that can defile
will enter we're going to be in a place
where none of these things exists and
most importantly we are going to be
completely reproduced in the character
of a Immortal Incorruptible man named
Jesus amen so there'll be no desire
that's why sin will not rise up a second
time and then
Hebrews 2 14 inasmuch then as the
children have partaken of Flesh and
Blood he himself that's Jesus shared in
the same that through death he might
destroy him
who had the power of death that is the
devil so the Devil Himself is going to
be destroyed and lastly in Malachi
chapter 4.
we find that how how completely is Satan
going to be destroyed root and Branch
can you have fruit if there's no Branch
can you have branches if there's no root
no the root itself that brings sin into
existence is destroyed no sin no Satan
no death praise the Lord is Right amen
thank you sir
all right sister Shelley I have your
question here and this is your
opportunity for a four-minute answer
here we go
can you please explain the truth about
the Rapture Theory that's from Lisa in
Ottawa Ontario and she texted that to us
Lisa I'm sorry I only have four minutes
to answer the perhaps your theory
teaches the secret coming of Christ that
will happen before tribulation and he
brings his people up and he leaves other
people on the Earth who are going to
have a second chance let's see what the
Bible says in Matthew 24 verse 22 just
write these down because I'm gonna have
to go quickly Matthew 24 22 Jesus is
talking about the end days in a time of
trouble and he says that had those days
not been shortened the elect would not
endure and survive so it doesn't he says
for the sake of the elect this time will
be shortened so it sounds like to me
we're going through the tribulation is
his second coming a secret let's look
the Bible describes it as an
earth-shattering event first
Thessalonians 4 16 Christ comes with the
voice of the Archangel with a shout and
a loud trumpet Luke 21
26-28 and Matthew 16 27 Jesus says he is
coming in up a Cloud of Glory and power
and great glory and he says the powers
of heaven will be shaken when he returns
with his angels Matthew 24 27 he said
his glorious appearing is going to flash
as as the lightning across the skies
from the East to the west of Revelation
1 7 says every eye will seem so let me
ask you when the skies recede as a
scroll
when he circles the globe at lightning
speed with all of these angels and this
noise that's right are you telling me
somebody's going to sleep through this
is this a secret Rapture Matthew 16
27 and revelation 22 and verse 12 says
he comes he's ready to render the
rewards to each person according to
their works so our Our Fate has been
determined our destiny is determined
before he returns at his second coming
he says that all who are in The Voice
there's going to be two resurrections
there's the resurrection of the
righteous there raise for life and then
there is a second resurrection that
Revelation 20 verses 5 through 6 tells
us is a thousand years later and these
are the people who were destroyed by the
brightness of his coming but now they
are resurrected and there is no second
chance for these people right you know
you alluded to a couple of scriptures
earlier but
first Thessalonians 4 15 and 17. says
that the righteous will by no means
precede into the presence of the Lord
before those who are asleep so we know
no one's there yet but he says in First
Corinthians 15 verses
51-54 behold I tell you a mystery in the
twinkling of an eye at the last trumpet
win at the last Trump that's right he
says we're all going to be changed in
the moment in the twinkling of an eye it
says the trumpet will sound the dead
will be raised Incorruptible and this
incorruption
the Mortal is putting on immortality so
the wicked don't have another chance you
look at second Thessalonians 1 7 and 8.
oh there's so much I've got here but the
bottom line let me read this real quick
second Peter 3 10 and 12 the day of the
Lord will come as the thief in the night
which the heavens will pass away with a
great noise and the elements will melt
with fervent heat both the earth and the
works that are in it will be burned up
therefore since all these things will be
dissolved what manner of person sought
you to be in holy conduct and godliness
looking for it hastening in the coming
of the day of the Lord because of which
the heavens will be dissolved being on
fire and the elements will melt with
fervent heat
amen amen thanks sister Shelley amen not
a secret exactly
all right brother Dinsey here's your
third question
did lot know that the two men that came
to his house were different
is that why he offered his daughters to
the men outside instead of the Angels
did he know that they were Holy Angels
that's from Becky in North Carolina and
she texted that to us
very good we thank you Becky for the
question and we go to Genesis chapter 19
to begin our answer now beginning in
verse 1 it says now the two angels came
to Sodom in the evening and lot was
sitting in the gate of Sodom when lot
saw them he rose to meet them and he
bowed him himself with his face toward
the ground and he said here now my lords
please turn to your servant's house and
spend the night and wash your feet then
you may rise early and go your way and
they said no but we will spend the night
in the open Square but he insisted
strongly why because he knew what the
city was like so they turned into him
and entered his house then he made them
a feast and baked unleavened bread and
they ate now before they lay down verse
4 the men of the city the men of the
Sodom both old and young all the people
from every quarter surrounded the house
so this uh moment here where the food
was prepared and they had time to eat
that was an opportunity for a lot to get
acquainted with them and surely their
conversation was not about the prices of
the produce or the sporting events of
the city these men spoke serious things
and by the conversation surely he
eventually realized wait a minute these
are not just men
but it wasn't until later when they
actually
strike everyone blind that you know a
lot realized they said wait a minute
these are not I mean and then of course
the conversation later you know that
they a lot knew who they were for sure
but in the beginning he may not have
known they just appear to be strangers
walking through
but eventually he found out so what
happens here in this story is that
we see lot offering his daughters
so that these men were not uh I'm gonna
say like it is rape and have uh
uh
illicit relationship with these men how
to describe it in a better language
that's the way it was so we have a lot
offering his daughters to these people
so they wouldn't do harm to them now
is this why he offered his daughters
because he thought they were Angels no
Lord by remaining in Sodom and Gomorrah
eventually all the wickedness of the
city began to blur in his mind what is
right what is wrong even his daughters
you see later as the story develops they
come up with this plan to uh
get a lot drunk and then at night they
have they go into the bedroom and of
course the story reveals that they
wanted to preserve the the the lineage
of lots so we see that their mind was
also confused about what is right and
what is wrong was it right for him to
offer his daughters absolutely not
these angels could take care of
themselves if they needed to and if we
saw that very clearly that they struck
people with blindness but notice how
Wicked these people were as you continue
reading in Genesis chapter nine you'll
see that they wearied themselves all
night even though they were blind yes
trying to reach the door
so this this story is in there to help
us understand that we shall not expose
ourselves to evil uh unnecessarily a lot
when he noticed how this city was he
should have got himself out of there but
he chose to remain why because
the deceitfulness of riches and the
influence of the city of course was
beginning to corrupt the righteous
morals that they had learned yes yes
thank you sir all right
Pastor John I've got your fourth and
final question okay where are we in the
timeline of Bible prophecy chapter 13 of
Revelation
also what role does Michael the
Archangel play in the last days that's
from Michael in Madison Wisconsin and he
texted that question to us okay since I
have three minutes for both questions
I'll just give you the quick version of
revelation 13. we are primarily between
verse 11 and verse 12 of Revelation to
chapter 13 verse 11 is the rise of
America as a Protestant nation and the
Bible talks about that in Revelation
chapter 12 and verse 16 when Satan tried
to wipe out the church Through The
Counter Reformation that took place in
Europe through ART and music and
literature and science The Counter
Reformation the Bible says that the
devil spewed water after the woman out
of his mouth but the Earth opened its
mouth and helped the woman now the Earth
introduces the how does this happen the
Bible says in Revelation 13 verse 11
then I saw another Beast coming up out
of the earth having two horns like a
lamb and he spoke as a dragon the two
horns one simply means a Protestant
Nation with a government that's a
republic by the people for the people it
was not like a government in Europe
where there was top down the church
dictated what the people did and the
people and the political leaders were
under the power of the church which is
sad uh there you know there's some
allusion to people thinking that the
existence for the church in America is
to control the government but where we
are in fact are between verses 11 and 12
and we already see some of verse 12
coming into being and he that is the
United States this land-like power with
the description of Christ the lamb we'll
exercise all the authority of the first
Beast which is the power of Rome the
Church of the Dark Ages in his presence
and cause those who dwell on the earth
to worship the first peace whose deadly
wound was healed that's where that's
headed so the United States right now is
in that transitionary period
that's why you have the Christian
nationalism that's the whole term I'm
looking for with this movement in
America is trying to
use religion to control the government
and when that happens the Bible says
where it's going to happen it's going to
go north so I was going to go south in
America now Michael
what's the position of Michael well the
position of Michael Michael is the
military name of Christ when you look at
the Bible's description you find that
when Daniel was in prayer uh the Bible
talked about that in Daniel chapter 10
verse 13 but the prince of the kingdom
of Persia withstood me 21 days and
behold Michael now you find this
continually there there are descriptive
words of Satan the Prince of Persia the
king of tire talking about this great
battle between light and darkness truth
and error then you find also talked
about again where how did Daniel find
Victory Michael stood up in his behalf
and then Revel Daniel 12 1 when the time
of Trouble Comes Michael Christ will
stand up you also find in Revelation
chapter 12 the war in heaven between
Darkness and Light Christ Michael fought
against the dragon and the dragon as
Angels fought and then you find in Jude
9 Michael the Archangel contending with
the devil over the body of Moses so
that's simply the role of Christ he is
the one who fights our battles for us
and where is he in the role of Last Day
Events he will stand up for his people
amen when the time of trouble comes but
he's standing up as Christ today for us
every moment of every day amen amen
thank you Pastor John
all right sister Shelley I have your
fourth and final question okay
in first Samuel chapter 28 verses 12-19
who did the medium of Endor bring up to
speak with Saul
they seem to have all the knowledge of
the situation of what Saul was inquiring
about that's from Denise in Pennsylvania
and she texted that to us okay Denise
you know in today's society we Embrace
psychics and seances and wizards and
mediums and channels God forbids such
practices
necromancy is the word for Conjuring up
the spirit supposedly the spirits of the
dead but the Bible refers to them as
familiar spirits these are demonic
Spirits when uh the demons who are under
judgment that's the third of the Angels
who followed Satan these are Fallen
Angels they're under judgment and
reserved for judgment till the second
coming of Jesus but we see in second
Corinthians 11 13-15 that they disguise
themselves as angels of Lights God
ordered any medium who was calling on
these demonic spirits to be put to death
you can look in Leviticus 20 in
Deuteronomy 13 for that so King Saul had
expelled these mediums in first Samuel
28 but now he's in a degenerated state
and he's actually wanting to consult
with one of these meetings and he's
asking for Samuel why Samuel had been
his mentor and when Saul rejected the
word of the Lord word through Samuel
God finally refused to communicate with
Saul he's in its first set first Samuel
28 verse 6. God wasn't going to
communicate with him anymore so here's
what first Samuel 28 12-19 says when the
woman the medium that's that Saul had
checked out when she saw Samuel now this
is going to be a satanic impersonation
of Samuel watch she cried with a loud
voice and the woman spoke to us all
saying why have you deceived me for your
soul and the King said to her do not be
afraid what do you see he didn't see
anything and the woman said to Saul I
see a spirit a sinning out of the earth
so he said to her what is his form he
hadn't seen anything and she says it's
an old man coming up covered with a
mantle and then the scripture says so
perceived that it was Samuel interesting
how whatever we want it to be it can be
and he stooped with his face to the
ground and bout now this Witch of Endor
did provide Supernatural information
by this demonic Spirit he was taunting
so he he tells Saul you're going to be
slain and what you know what first
Chronicles 10 13 says listen to this
Saul was slain quote for asking counsel
of one that had a familiar Spirit to
inquire of it and inquired not of the
Lord so scripture predicts we're going
to have a whole lot more of these
impersonations and appearances at the
end of time yes know that they are not
the spirit of The Departed because the
Bible says that when we're dead we know
nothing we're resting peacefully till
the time comes
don't be deceived amen we've got to know
the word
amen thank you sister
all right brother Dinsey I've got your
fourth and final question and there's
your opportunity for a four minute
answer bless your heart
all right here we go
would you say that the European Union is
the ten toes in the Book of Daniel and
this person texted this question to us
very good uh let's talk about the
European Union and the question is is
the ten toes are they the ten toes of
the Book of Daniel first of all if
you're looking for 10 you have to
understand the European Union is 27
countries it says by going to the
internet you find the European Union
it's an economic political union of 27
countries it operates an internal or
single Market which allows free
movements of goods Capital Services and
people between member states they have
been trying to find Unity for many many
years actually hundreds of years but the
Bible says that they will not leave one
to another as you read there in the Book
of Daniel chapter Two uh at this point
in time they're not even in agreement
concerning the Euro the Euro everybody
knows about the euro is setting
competition with the US dollar the euro
is the official currency of 19 out of
the 27 member states of the European
Union
and so we have they they have tried to
unite for many uh a few hundred years
actually you can look on the internet
and see that the kings of the different
countries have tried to intermarry one
with another uh because the the Bible
says that uh they shall mingle with the
seed of men they try to intermingle by
marrying to stop all the wars between
each other
they were trying to marry this king with
the I mean this princess with the prince
of the other so that eventually you say
well we're all family here why fight but
they will still fight because people
wanted to be on top and not on the
bottom let's look at Daniel chapter 2
verse 40 to 44 and it says in the fourth
Kingdom shall be as strong as iron in as
much as iron breaks in pieces and
shatters everything and like iron cross
that crushes that Kingdom will break in
pieces and Crush all the others whereas
you saw defeat antols partly of Potter's
clay and partly of iron the kingdom
shall be divided
yet the strength of the iron shall be in
it just as you saw the iron mixed with
ceramic clay and as the toes of the feet
were partly of iron and partly of clay
so the kingdom shall be partly strong
and partly fragile
as you saw iron mixed with ceramic clay
they will mingle with the seed of men
but they will not adhere or cleave one
to another as it says in the King James
just as iron does not mix with Clay but
the good news is found in Daniel chapter
2 verse 44. amen let's go that's right
and in the days of these Kings these are
these are the days we're living in in
the days of these Kings the god of
heaven will set up a kingdom which shall
never be destroyed amen and the kingdom
shall not be left to other people it
shall breaking pieces and consume all
these kingdoms and it shall stand
forever amen praise the Lord for that so
the question that you have asked is
would you say the European Union is the
10 toes of the Book of Daniel
within the Europe the European Union and
Western Europe yes you can say they are
there which countries they are we are
not told but
they shall try to cleave one to another
uh you have heard about Revelation 13 we
are moving towards the Fulfillment of
Revelation 13 and as I read before the
good news is that in the days of these
games God is going to set up a kingdom
which shall never have an end and I hope
that you are a part of this Kingdom and
if you're not if you haven't given your
heart to the Lord Jesus Christ do so
before it's too late and today is a good
day to do that amen amen thank you
brother you know it's great to sit
around the table with like family and
study the word of God and this has been
really great I've been blessed by this I
hope you were blessed by it as well
we've found the answers in God's word
and that's where you can do the same
study God's word it's true it's powerful
it can change your life
so we were about to run out of time we
want to take a little break so we can
put on the screen some information to
let you know how you can participate
with sending in your questions to 3abn
today Bible q a so stay tuned for that
information don't go away we'll be right
back
if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible q a
then tell your friends each Monday will
bring you a fresh program answering the
Bible questions you send us using God's
holy word to shed light on those texts
that seem difficult to understand to
have your questions answered on a future
program just email them to us at bibleqa
at 3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv
you may also text your questions to
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 be sure to include your
name and where you live and then
watch3ab in Bible q a for answers from
God's word
well our time is almost up it's gone by
really fast but before we go I want to
get some final thoughts from our
panelists sister Shelly I just want to
reiterate that Supernatural
manifestations are going to increase in
the end times we see that in Revelation
in Matthew in second Thessalonians let
me write these scriptures down
Ecclesiastes 9 5 and verse 10 and Psalm
146 verse 4 say the dead know nothing
they are in an unconscious sleep
Psalm 115 17 job 3 11 and 13 the resting
peacefully they don't even know what's
going on in the Earth the dead cannot
talk to you Amen period amen thank you
sister
brother Lindsay I like to say something
concerning what we see there at the end
of Daniel chapter 2 and I Rejoice to
know that we are living in the time of
the end all of the kingdoms presented in
Daniel chapter Two they are behind us
you can look at history and see how
these things were fulfilled we are
living in the time of the end and I hope
and encourage you to be prepared for the
soon return of our Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ amen amen yes I talk about
incarceration of the devil you know one
of the questions that most people don't
ask is how long is the devil going to be
around well he is the root of all evil
if he's not around where is evil going
to come from so that whole issue is
being settled now and I'm going to
appeal to you make your decision that
you can be in the Kingdom where there is
no more sin Malachi 4 1. the devil
doesn't exist there they don't have bad
neighbors nobody's trying to break into
your house nothing that defiles will
enter in we're making the decision now
to live in an eternally sin-free
death-free corruption-free world and
where sin will never rise up again and
do you know what that means if it did
rise up it really meant that Jesus
Christ was not sufficient to destroy sin
and he has been sufficient quite
sufficient exactly amen well thank you
so much Pamela and thank you for joining
us I hope that you will come back and
study God's word with us again
but until then God bless and we'll see
you soon
thank you
[Music]
foreign